we're on test 5 section 9 on page 679
let's do some problems problem number
one
problem one
if six cars out of 10 on assembly line
are red what is the probability that a
car selected at random from the assembly
line will be red
well six out of ten are red so if i take
a random one i have a six and ten chance
of getting a red car
if you look at the choices there is no
six over ten but you can see that this
can be reduced if you divide the top and
the bottom
by 2 you get 3
over 5. so this is really just an
exercise in reducing a fraction to its
lowest common
or simplified form so the answer is b
problem two
let me draw that diagram
so i have a triangle let's see
try my best to draw this
there's an altitude that comes down to
the center
splits
and then what do they write
they write
this angle right here is
w
this is x
y
z
over here
and they say note figure not drawn to
scale
a b is equal to b c o i had to draw the
letters in
so a
b
c
and then
d
so they say that a b is equal to b c
so a b
is equal to b c so immediately a trigger
should go off in your head if two sides
are equal what does it say about kind of
the base angles or their corresponding
angles that means that those are also
going to be equal
so if those two
sides are equal then we also know that
these two angles are equal that should
immediately be a trigger in your head
that we know that w is equal to z okay
what's the next part of the information
and bd this is bd
it bisects ac so bisects means it
essentially intersects it at its
midpoint so that also tells us that
this distance here
from a to d is the same as the distance
from d to c
which of the following cannot be
concluded
that w is equal to x
that let's see w is equal to x
i do that immediately i don't even know
how i can conclude let's look at the
other choices w is equal to z well w is
equal to z can definitely be concluded
that's choice b so we know that choice b
is w equals z we know this isn't it
because we concluded that immediately
choice c
is that x is equal to y x is equal to y
that actually can be concluded how do we
know that well we since this bisects
this line
we know that
and and this is an isosceles triangle
even though that's not how i drew it
right i drew this
this this triangle is completely
symmetric right maybe i should draw a
little bit better how do i know it's
completely symmetric
because this side is equal to this side
that is equal to that
and this side is equal to this side
right and of course this side is equal
to that side
and actually we can also conclude that
this is a 90 degree angle because if
this was anything other than a 90 degree
angle this wouldn't be able to bisect at
the base
so
choice c
we know we actually can deduce that x is
equal to y so that's not the answer
choice d is a d is equal to dc
well they essentially told us that when
they said bd inter bisects ac so that's
not our answer
choice e
b d is perpendicular ac and i just said
the triangle is completely symmetric and
given that it's an isosceles triangle
the only way that bd can bisect this
bottom line is if it's perpendicular
so we can also rule out e so our answer
really is a
and really there was no way that we
could figure out
and a good way of thinking about that is
actually
we could make this point we could make
the length of this line this length bd
arbitrarily high because they gave us no
information the triangle could look like
this
it could look like that
or it could look like this
based on the information they gave us so
the angle these angles
could change
arbitrarily so we really don't know what
those angles are
next problem
problem three
switch colors i'm about to sneeze
excuse me
if 30 of m is 40 so 0.3 m that's 30 of m
is equal to 40.
what is 15
percent of m what is 0.15 of m
you could solve this divide both sides
by 0.3 et cetera et cetera but
the important thing to recognize is that
15 or 0.15 is half of 0.13
right
so if
15 is half of 0.3 or 30 percent then 15
percent m is going to be half of
whatever 30 m is so it's going to be
equal to 20. another thing you could
have done if that's not completely
obvious take this top equation and
multiply by one-half
then you'll get 0.15 m
is equal to 20.
that's choice b
problem four
if n is any negative number so n is less
than zero it's a negative number which
of the following must be positive
must be positive so i can already tell
you that the only way you can take a
negative number and make it positive is
either if you square it or if you
multiply it by another negative number
so let's see or if you if you subtract
it actually now that i look at the
choices so i could tell you you know a n
over 2. that's definitely going to be a
negative number
b
is definitely going to be negative
you're multiplying by positive
c you're just adding something to it so
it still could be negative
if that's like negative 10 or something
right
d you're just subtracting from it you're
just going to make it more negative
e 2 minus n
2 minus n
this will definitely result in a
positive number why
because let's say that you could express
n as the product of a negative number
let's say n is equal to minus p
where p is some positive number right
you can represent any negative number
like that
then 2 minus n is the same thing as 2
minus minus p
which is the same thing as 2 plus p
and we said p is a positive number
so there we go so choice number 4 is
definitely e
and you could try it out number try it
out with the number n equals negative 10
and i think it should work out
next problem problem number five
the ratio 1.2 to 1 1.2 to 1
is equal to which of the following
ratios
so they have give us a bunch of choices
one point two to one so it's a little
bit more than one to one
so we could look at one to two now
that's
that that makes no sense because one is
smaller than two
twelve to one
12 is 12 times 1 not just you know 1.2
times 1 right so you're just looking for
a ratio where the the first number is
1.2 times the second number 5 to 6
that's choice c that doesn't work
because 5 is less than 6. choice d six
to five i think we hit it because six is
just a little bit more than five and
actually if you wanted to confirm that
why don't you want you divide the top
and the bottom by five so five goes into
six
how many times five goes into six one
time
five denominator how many times does
five go into
ten really is two five goes into six one
point two times so the answer is six to
five
next problem
see if i have time to do this
clear image invert colors
the legend of a certain pictograph shows
that this thing
is equal to 5 million new homes
approximately how many new homes are
represented by the symbols
so they drew that three and a half times
one
two
three and then they draw half a house
right that's half a house
so these three are going to be what this
is 3 times 5
which is equal to 15 million homes
right
and then this is half a house that's
what i tried to draw what they drew in
the diagram so half house is what 2.5
million houses it's just half of a house
half of the 5 million so it's 15 million
plus 2.5 it equals
17.5 million homes and that is choice d
you might be tempted to say that this
represents half a million homes but
remember this represents half of one of
these pictures and one of these pictures
represents five million homes so this is
two and a half million this is two and a
half
not 0.5
see in the next video